[Applause]
Wow thank you for the invitation
described in particular invitation to
come and speak with you today
Irish call with some flips we do here
looking up and nice this one I don't
know be good I recall with some fondness
along cab ride that Skylar and I took
what time in Croatia in which we out of
the I think sheer boredom of the
four-hour taxi ride back to the airport
came up with several interesting
speculative proposals for programmable
matter including as I recall using the
distributions of astronomic
constellations as a memory storage
arrays so my my talk today is a bit more
philosophical than some of the others
and I think well to this I I hope this
will be useful in this in this way I
think as a writer as a theorist I think
that at this point the moment in which
we think of philosophy somebody might be
applied to the questions of Technology
and choice may need to be reversed at
this point that in steroids our
technologies are ahead of our capacity
to conceptualize their implications and
so maybe part of the reason that some of
our work doesn't have the impact on the
world that we would like it to at scale
is as much of a problem for conceptual
models as it is of mechanical models
since that time Skyler and I this
conversation MIT press has recently
published a book of mine called the
stack on software and sovereignty for
which some of the practical design
issues of programmable matter are
central to a theory of the geopolitics
of planetary scale computation and its
impact on what we might call Geo design
there's two key arguments of the book
one is that planetary scale computation
growth distorts and deforms traditional
Westphalian logics of political
geography and creates new territories in
its own
image and that these different genres of
computation smart grids cloud platforms
mobile apps smart cities IOT automation
cetera can be seen not as so many
species of computation evolving on their
own but as forming a kind of coherent
whole these technologies align layer by
layer into something like a vast if also
incomplete pervasive if also irregular
accidental mega structure which we call
the stack a computational apparatus and
a new governing architecture at the same
time it is comprised of ecological flows
becoming sites of intensive sensing
quantification and governance of cloud
platform spurring platform economies
creating virtual geographies in its own
image for which we see contemporary
cloud platforms and absorbing
traditional core functions of the state
and vice versa cities forming vast
discontinuous networks as they weave
their borders into enclaves or escape
routes virtual addressing systems
locating billions of entities and events
into unfamiliar Maps interfaces
presenting vibrant augmentations of
reality standing in for extended
cognition users both human and non-human
populating this tangled apparatus this
accidental micro structure in which we
find ourselves the in that book as well
as the one that I'm writing now I call
for a materialism that is perhaps more
closely tuned to the philosophical
provocations of actual matter itself
especially what we now know about
matters programmability that we did not
know until recently which I think has
some profound effects for how we might
understand ourselves as well as matter
and so we would react the question of
how it is that matter may assemble
itself into a form that produces effects
that we would recognize as intelligence
including the frontal cortex of Homo
sapiens but also how it assembles itself
as AI either other non-carbon-based
forms of intelligence and and so in
terms of programming matter we're
interested that is in a kind
geology of AI so first program planetary
scale computation involves the entire
Earth of in its operations from which
silica steel and all matter of Conflict
Minerals are drawn computation that is
is not virtual it is a deeply physical
event and the stack has an enormous
appetite for molecules of interest and
distributing them into our pockets our
laps and our landfills the chemistry's
and terawatts that feed the stack and us
through it forced us to reckon that the
ponderous heaviness of the cloud will be
a key driver for geopolitical frictions
to come will the platform efficiencies
of the stack provide the lightness
necessary for a new subtractive
modernity an engine of a sustainable
counter industrialization or will it
will its appetite finally suck
everything into its collapsing cores of
data centers buried under mountains the
last race the climate itself the last
enemy and regarding the materials at
work silica of course is the least of
the problem billions of Earthlings
everywhere carry little bits of Africa
around with them in their pockets the
stacks Terra forms the host planet by
drinking and vomiting it's elemental
juices and spitting up mobile phones any
bit of matter or even even though those
more prosaic is further more dependent
upon sensing apparatus is capable of
transforming biochemical events into
data such that other media could
assemble these into descriptive which
may then then descriptive models which
then may provide for predictive models
in turn and so the extrapolation if you
like of planetary surfaces as epidermis
has long been linked with the
conceptualization of climatic
measurements and prediction for example
such as the history of weather
programmability resides we might say in
that layer between the original and
artificial planetary computers and the
plasticity by which one might affect the
other
when a material public is based on a
truly ubiquitous computational
infrastructures form the political
formulations that it that would that
would cohere might be based on the
aggregation of encounters and
relationships between persons and things
and material events including especially
those in which people are not directly
involved but even if everything is seen
and registered in this way
not everything sees or works back on
what it sees in the same way and so
economic centers from gold standard to
carbon pricing to the to the energy bill
for Bitcoin miners we are quickly
confronted with the fundamental
questions of how matter and energy may
contain Co here represent guarantee or
exchange value that is with Bitcoin with
blockchains we may in theory induce
currencies that refer to energy
expenditure necessary to the energy
expenditure necessary to calculate them
into existence and to the extent that
they are at least provisionally
programmable we have then currencies
that defer their apparent lack of
materiality by deferring in to hardware
instead of tokens that is energy itself
may not be programmable directly in this
way but currencies that represent energy
expenditures can be and so for a more
speculative eco economics perhaps the
lesson for carbon is to make it a lesson
for us to make the carbon chain more
ubiquitous expanding the scope of the
sovereign wallet to include composite
users that are as well the major carbon
sinks part of the design question we may
say has to do with interpreting the
status of the image of the world that
would be created by this kind of program
as well as that mechanisms own image of
itself and the way that it governs the
planet by governing its model of the
planet that model is built on the
interrelationship as I say between
non-human biology's and chemistry's
much and so the images that the designer
can deduce and produce serve as well for
the representational agency of matter
that otherwise would be invisible to
itself beyond its most local chemical
interactions as they're next then we
would want to ask after intelligence
computation and matter how computation
has become a kind of solvent in which
the particular forms of algorithmic
reasons dissolve into matter we take it
then the computation was discovered more
than it was invented or at least as much
as it was invented and we take it that
it is one of the ways that matter in
whatever form achieves intelligence
through procedural abstraction among
these stay piant brain tissue is another
way that matter has achieved
intelligence in ways that are both
clearly and clearly not computational in
the conventional sense and we take it
that the solution or this dissolution of
synthetic computation into matter or
software into urban fabric provide the
landscape of inorganic forms as sort of
distributed intelligence because because
it provides them for the capacity for
abstraction that is intelligence as
abstraction computation is intelligence
computation as abstraction so this
perspective I think should account for
at least two but probably rather
different understandings one would
recognize that intelligence and
knowledge is always distributed among
multiple positions in forms of life both
similar and dissimilar to one another
and that no single neuroanatomical
disposition has a privileged monopoly on
how to think intelligently what might
qualify as intelligence is not
duty-bound to species or phylum
nor in its capacity for abstraction the
ability of any organism however
primitive to map its surroundings
particularly in relation to the basic
terms of friend food and foe is a
primordial abstraction which from which
we do not graduate so much as learn to
develop into something like reason
and it's local human variations so like
protozoa lucilia feeling about to figure
out what's out there or like humans
looking and tasting and imagining
patterns
today's forms of AI or sometimes
augmented by various technologies of
machine cognition machine sensation
machine vision that allowed them to see
and sense the world out there and to
abstract the forms of a mechanically
embodied intelligence but deliberately
programmed and emerging unexpectedly and
in time should complex general AI arrive
it would not be human-like unless we
insist that it pretend to be so because
one assumes the idea that intelligence
could be both real and inhuman at the
same time is somehow morally or
psychologically intolerable instead of
nurturing this bigotry we would do
better to allow that in our universe
thinking is a much more diverse even
alien phenomenon than our own particular
case the real philosophical essence of
AI then or will have less to do with
humans teaching machines how to think
than with machines teaching humans a
fuller and truer range of what thinking
can be but first I want to deal with
deeper into the question of AI not some
AI in a petri dish or AI as if it were a
kind of synthetic philosopher but rather
AI as a landscape scale enterprise for
which information sensing and processing
exist in complex economic niches even or
especially because AI evolved back and
forth between real technology and
philosophical experiments AI epistemic
and urban careers cannot be disentangled
except through rather artificial
conditions that is if intelligence is
one way that matter organizes itself
into durable complexity then the special
form of that complexity is the city
settled accumulation of material
intelligence both human and inhuman and
so as a AI becomes more sophisticated
what will be its urban project
we try to see they not in terms of how
we think that we think is a sort of
virtual human cognition serving Oz but
rather as thinking and but as rather
thinking and embodying another spot than
we do on a larger and shared continuum
of material intelligence this is as I
hinted fundamentally bound up with
sensing with urban scale Network arise
in attendant AIS we see that the
boundaries between we're sensing stops
and information processing begins is
very muddy sometimes like with the skin
of cuttlefish the thinking happens in
the skin sometimes is with various nano
and bioengineering a point of important
conversion between bits and atoms is for
it is how matter and sometimes new new
materials that can be designed to sense
or arguably interpret the scope and
sphere at the urban scale this synthetic
bio semiosis blends with those always
those already at work in many cases the
pairing of synthetic sensing vision for
example with evolutionary robotics
allows for simple artificial species to
perform intelligence because they have
what amounts to a functionally embodied
perceptual model location in the world
the heuristic model habitat is
inseparable from how the AI manipulates
the situation situated problem space
they think because they can see now the
city any city is home to millions of
species from microbes to insects to
vegetation to say piant mammals it's a
living bacteria logical and
immunological to molt the situated
ecology of predation and symbiosis
competitive and sexual selections across
multiple scales and now we insert
landscape scale sensing and evolutionary
robotics into this the a our city may be
embodying itself but not as humans do
there's a commingling of diverse sensors
of light and air and sound and chemistry
drawing a landscape of sensing and
thinking little species
partially embodied discreetly with one
another partially co embodied with one
another as their information inputs are
aggregated and modeled and acted upon in
various pluralities Homo sapiens come
equipped with a extraordinary array of
sensory faculties which may have we know
before they're augmented by synthetic
layers and various ratios ranging from
the sensors and trackers in our phones
that we carry about like mules to more
intimate media of artificial images and
sounds situating ourselves in this
expanded field we are both sensors and
sensed on the one hand we are a primary
sapient actor in this drama supervising
an orchestra of sensing technologies
each individually capable of function of
functional processing and together of
certain forms of emergent intelligence
as our neurons or other cells on the
other we are not we are not only the
subject of the scenario we are also its
subject matter that wider urban
landscape of synthetic sensory systems
is not only a platform through which we
extend and extrapolate our capacities
for abstraction it is also capable of
other sorts of abstractions on its own
and so it's not just AI in the city but
but nested AI Co embodied as the city
would but based on a very different
organism to signal to niche talk to
population to genome dynamics and
structures their work in short we should
imagine an AI urbanism in terms of vanos
called stroll into the field populated
by intermingling but mutually oblivious
little life worlds and or in terms of de
luces parable of the tick the later
weighing in late laying in wait for some
threshold event should come its way at
which point it triggers its programmed
response out into its own little void
many of our urban sensors and their
limited forms of a I work in sit with
similar within a similar way and with
similar nobility more versatile
synthetic intelligence occupy more
complex on the veldt
summer predator and prey summer motion
summer flowering summer pollinating and
as we stroll among them we may be
registered by them or we may be ignored
we may be a primary cause of concern or
we may be passing interference in an
evolutionary dynamic in which we are
neither protagonist nor target the
cities we build are in this way not only
the habitat again about which AI may
learn contextual knowledge they are the
distributed sensor apparatus with which
an AI embodies that context the city
layer of the stack as platform and as
governing apparatus is self
incorporating in this way and so
simultaneously simultaneous with the
collapse of biodiversity and other
contexts we also see at least a strong
potential for an explosion of new
species taking form through robotics
synthetic biology and AI we can't of
course see the latter as replacements
for the former and yet there they are
I'll close with a couple other remarks
one of the other thing I would have
perhaps shared if we've given a more
time was a short story that I'm writing
now on a project to teach disappearing
human languages to AI that might hold
them a kind of unset of a seed bank a
kind of ontology bank until then I'll
conclude with these thoughts in
Stanislaw lambs in Tchaikovsky's Solaris
the surface of the planet ocean was
sentient as you know here on planet
Earth the strategy toward sentience
includes layered networks of neurons in
the folded gray matter of animal brains
particularly but not exclusively the
cerebal cortex of primates namely humans
we are as nikolai fedorov wrote over a
century ago the matter in medium through
which the planet thinks having folded
some of its matter into the shape of
brains in waiting a few million years
for these blobs to sorted out one of the
things the earth recently figured out is
its own age four point six hundred seven
billion years old a competent figure for
which
ladies 1953 the same year that Beckett
premiered Waiting for Godot we as the
Earth's digestive residue were able to
discover and know the planets own
duration quite impressive considering
how for most of our existence we thought
that the planet ran on our time so was
this project in which the Earth's
formulated from itself
a biochemical intensity aka humans that
would prove capable of of figuring out
how old it is worth the cost we could
deduce the age primarily through the
geologic project source and sourcing
data through mining a Faustian bargain
to top it all was discovering the
fundamental truth worth exhuming
millions of years of pre Mesozoic bio
matter for a two century fuel supply and
inauguration of mass extinction I asked
my students if they thought it was worth
it and they were split perhaps though
the MOU pertinent question would be what
would make it worth it must the
accomplishment of this Copernican
aesthetic epistemic disenchantment
destroy or at least threaten that which
it knows is this a necessary outcome or
is it only or is this only a kind of
provisional damage that would make for a
more durable relationship between knower
and known and what of desire then the
tropes of Eros and Thanatos our other
relationship to matter are probably
deceptive it is not I think a sad
destiny to the inter woven with alien
matter other diagrams are possible and
atomic and economic our own bodies in
and as this earthly landscape of matter
are only the default settings you might
say they are not destiny chemistry as
usual may ultimately drive the most
radical forms of the political and
philosophical imaginary
a culinary materialism yes rubbing the
Clinton raw arguably the Anthropocene
itself is do less to technology run amok
than to the humanist project that
understands the world as having been
given for our needs and created in our
image the experience of our experience
taken as the more essential value among
other things this makes it far too
difficult to see the inevitable whether
we wanted to or not
geoengineering GeoDesign project for
what it really is or what it should be
that is something more like molecular
gastronomy at landscape scale a restored
and resore 'td ecology designed to taste
itself in new forms of richly spiced and
imaginatively sauced mutual ingestion a
last word before tomorrow when
confronted directly or indirectly with
the promise lists promise less
implications of ecological indifference
to cultural traditions hominids will
vote for sovereigns who promise to bind
them back together somehow and who claim
powers to make reality obey the tribal
narrative by rituals of public voice
these arbitrary yarns are apparently
made real through a magical politics of
representation and identification what
Carl Schmitt called political theology
comes into its own when the function of
the state is to provide what amounts to
a religious plotline as public and
policies are drawn by regional myths and
hemispherical gross ROM we literally
vote for mind over matter matter however
is unconvinced or in other words a fire
broke out backstage in a theater the
clown came out to warn the public they
thought it was a joke and applauded he
repeated it the claim was even greater I
think that's how the world will end will
come to an end to general applause from
wits who believe it's a joke
thank you
[Applause]